hey youtubers it's Charlie so I haven't
done Walking Dead in a while and Norman
Reedus has been going crazy on that
custom motorcycle of his so I thought it
was time to do another Daryl Dixon video
I mean how many other people on the show
can tell a walker to shut up he's one of
the few people that acknowledges the
absurdity of their situation like we are
in the apocalypse this is ridiculous so
this is gonna be my top 10 Daryl Dixon
facts careful for spoilers for it for
everything that's happened on the show
so far if you're behind you need to
catch up it's all on Netflix so here we
go number one Daryl Dixon
not a character from the comic books
even though the main shows directly
adapted from comic book storylines Daryl
Dixon is an original creation of the
show why the TV shows adapted from
comics changed characters so much
usually it's just because they find an
actor that they really liked it doesn't
fit one of the pre-existing comic book
characters so they invent a new
character based on the narrative that
they want to tell number two he's a
badass mechanic in season five Aaron had
a bunch of spare motorcycle parts that
he'd been collecting but when he learned
about Daryl skills he gave them to him
mostly as a peace offering
in it worked big time behind the scenes
the show just wanted to give his
character something really awesome so
they built him a custom motorcycle uh
you know obviously Norman Reedus the
actor didn't build that but it's a
special custom bike it's one-of-a-kind
it actually works and the production
spent a ton of money on it
because it is awesome number three
despite a super racist upbringing with
his brother Merle he's overcome that and
become really good friends with all the
non-white characters on the show inside
the survivors if you look way back to
the early seasons like what when he
first was getting to know Glenn Merle
made this really big racist slur he was
like I tried to kill that chick nearly
killed that Chinese kid and Daryl speaks
up and says he's Korean man and Merle of
course being super racist just says
whatever doesn't matter I just can't go
with you so even early Darrell it's like
super rough around the edges is
overcoming this really awful passive is
speaking of which number four despite
being severely physically abused as a
child by his father he started to work
through that with the help of Beth may
she rest in peace and Carol during
season 4 when he had his little field
trip with Beth he started to explain to
her for the
time he starts to open up about how
terrible things were when he was a child
you kind of learned why he and Merle
bonded so much you know just because
they only had each other like their
father was just so terrible so even
though Daryl probably recognized Merle
was an awful person he clung to him
because that was all he had until he
found the survivors in season 5 you kind
of see the beginning of him starting to
work through that history of abuse with
Carol who had also endured a lot of
abuse from her husband Edie
may he not rest in peace Daryl Dixon a
great example of a character trying to
deal with abuse successfully number five
he is great and naming babies so way way
back when Judith was first born before
they had a name for he asked Carl you
know do you have a name and Carlos like
well there's Carol
Andrea Amy Patricia Jackie Laurie I
don't know and Daryl suggests little
ass-kicker as he cradles baby Judith
forget being awesome with naming babies
just you know Daryl smiling while
holding baby Judith is probably why the
female fandom is so crazy about Daryl
Dixon in addition to the fact that he's
kind of like a rescue puppy number six
he found the magical poncho so a couple
seasons ago Daryl you know just as dirty
as ever finds this ratty old poncho and
his crit rating goes through the roof
with the crossbow in subsequent seasons
other people appeared wearing the poncho
and nothing really came of it it was
just his offhanded thing it even ended
up being this really ill omen by the end
of its life when someone at terminus was
walking around with it they all noticed
and said hey where did you get all this
gear this used to belong to our friends
so we can just consider that the magical
Poncho's properties are bonded to
Daryl's DNA so like the minute he finds
the new artifact it kind of imprints on
him so that nobody else can use it we do
see you know very hot looking person
here sitting on the motorcycle with them
so hopefully nothing bad happens to her
but I laugh so hard as someone tries to
steal his motorcycle in season six and
then totally eats [ __ ] all over the
pavement you try to steal the bike
you're gonna end up being a hamburger
for a bunch of walkers number seven he
is not a coward there are a couple
characters on the show that have shown
true courage killing someone that they
loved because they knew that it was the
right thing
do when he finds his brother at the end
of season 3 who's been bitten and turned
he could have chose to walk away but he
knows in his heart that the right thing
to do
to put his brother to rest is to end
zombie Merle so he stabs him in the head
a few times and then we see him riding
into frame in a later scene on Murrells
bike as a way of eulogizing him that's
one of the reasons why they paid so much
special attention when they were first
filming Daryl's bike in season 5 the
bike 2-0 used to be a big reminder of
Merle but I mean obviously now that he
has a new bike it's more representative
of his freedom
a lot of the comic book volumes that
they passed through through season 5
like the storylines play a lot on the
idea of the survivors being trapped
inside the Alexandria safe zone
not so much protected more like trapped
in fact I think no way out is actually
where you should probably start reading
if you want to read the comics that's a
that's about where we are on the show
right now in terms of the story line
number 8 he's not so high on himself
that he's above playing games and
broening out in the name of survival
way back when Martinez was still on the
show back during season 3 Daryl has like
the most macho bro out contest with him
to see who can kill the most walkers
which is both fun to watch and super
practical so you're gonna have a contest
on the show you might as well make it
about killing as many walkers as
possible if anybody's gonna pick up that
tradition with him in season 6 it would
be Abraham Abraham is the quintessential
bro of the group now now that Daryl
started to become more of like a
Lebowski's then type dude
speaking of which number 9 he is not
afraid to cry probably the most famous
incident being when he had to kill his
brother Merle so so we'll give him at
not the most manly thing in the world
but that's never been what his character
is about he's been more like a feral
animal that's slowly being domesticated
with the help of Rambo Stepford wife
Carol they kinda have a symbiotic
relationship to that effect too like she
softens Daryl up Daryl softens her up
she would be like way more tiger mom if
he wasn't around he is one of the few
people that can get her to drop her
Rambo mode like she's normal around Rick
like she doesn't [ __ ] Rick but when
she's around Daryl she shows actual
tenderness and violate number 10 he is
almost unkillable
according to Robert Kirkman so there's
this really funny conversation that
Kirkman said he had with Norman
all the actors on the show are always
worried that they're gonna be killed off
so they're always asking Kirkman every
chance they get hey man I'm not gonna
get killed off am i I just want to know
am I gonna make it to the next season
Kirkman said to him before season 5
started hey man you're like the most
popular character on the show I think
you're gonna be fine dude as much as it
makes you upset to know that a character
is never gonna die I mean there's always
the small chance that he could die
you love the character so much that you
give the contrivance a pass is that
going to see a big blockbuster movie
like Mission Impossible and you're like
okay yeah you know Tom Cruise probably
not gonna die until he wants to stop
making Mission Impossible movies so the
plot isn't so much about when he's going
to die it's more about his character
development going from wild child feral
animal in season 1 all the way to
motorcycle riding crossbow Lebowski
character if he starts writing poetry
the universe is going to implode so
here's my big question for you guys what
are your favorite facts about Norman
Reedus in real life are Daryl Dixon on
the show he might not be the first
character you point out and say like he
is the hero of the show but he's kind of
like Wolverine like he's like the most
fun character on the show way more fun
than Rick Grimes
so most you guys if you are up on your
Walking Dead Season 6 info or you've
been watching my Walking Dead videos
since Comic Con you probably know
Walking Dead is going to start the
second week in October I mean it's it's
typically the week it starts every year
but fear the walking dead the spin-off
show is starting at the end of August
I'm gonna be doing videos for everything
I'll probably even have some cool stuff
from Skybound to give away so I'm
actually just gonna start my Walking
Dead giveaway now my weekly giveaway so
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I just I picked the winner from
the comments is how it works so as we
get a little bit closer to the fear of
The Walking Dead premiere which is at
the end of August I'm gonna start doing
fear The Walking Dead videos it's
totally inside The Walking Dead universe
it's just a new cast of characters on
the opposite side of the United States
so like right now on the main show
they're up in Washington DC they're up
in that area the spin-off show is gonna
happen in Los Angeles that's where it's
taking place and it starts when Rick is
in the coma I've already done a few
videos for it so I'll had some links in
the description a lot of you guys have
also asked me to make Walking Dead
telltale videos on my video game channel
totally loved the game right now I'm
trying to finish Batman Arkham Knight
and then I'm gonna play my way through
Game of Thrones episode 5 so I will do
walkies at telltale eventually but it's
just like it's like the number 3 thing
on my list if there are any videos for
the show that you guys want me to do
just let me know so just in case you
guys haven't seen it I did a Walking
Dead Season 6 trailer breakdown you can
click here to watch that just remember
that they totally mess with our heads
whenever they cut two trailers so it's
like a false narrative that they tell
and you can click here it's learn why
the Internet's blowing up about Channing
Tatum's gambit movie it might be like
self-destructing so thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight